I don't know too much about what's going
on at McDonald's stores or as they'd
like to call the restaurants in terms of
the vibe the food the clientele I
haven't been to a McDonald's or any of
that type of a store I think something
like 17 years but what I do know is that
lots of those jobs are going to be
replaced by machines and I've told you
about some reports from the last couple
of years
of testing of automated ordering kiosks
at Wendy's in at McDonald's etcetera and
during the presidential campaign as I
told you neither candidate was really
discussing technological automation uh
I'll bring jobs back I'll create jobs
blah blah blah no real discussion of the
impact of robots and Technology on jobs
well McDonald's has now announced wait
for it that they will be bringing their
automated kiosks and mobile payments to
all United States locations right now
about 500 stores in Florida New York and
California have these automated ordering
stations restaurants in Chicago Boston
San Francisco Seattle and DC will be
getting them next year the way it works
is a customer walks in places their
order at a touchscreen they get a number
with a digital locator which then tells
the staff in the kitchen where the or
the factory is maybe we should be
describing it where the customer is
sitting once it's ready to serve a
McDonald's employee comes out and
delivers the food right to the table
boom get rid of employees simple and
easy and this is all being wrapped up
with the fight for a $15 minimum fast
food wage and those who are against the
higher minimum wage uh are saying well
if you raise the minimum wage then this
is what restaurants are going to do and
it is true that the places that are
first instituting this in 2017 are some
of these cities and states with higher
minimum wages uh that's not going to
change the big picture of this which is
these jobs are getting replaced with
machines and totally yeah and you know
those people who always complain that
they may have a tough time communicating
with some of the sales representatives
yeah people running this the store there
yeah
they're gonna have a much tougher time
using these kiosks so I think they're
going to be effective the most
negatively
you think I mean I don't know what they
are the most negatively but but yeah
they're gonna be affected by and they're
gonna be complaining even more I was
thinking that this would actually ensure
a more accurate order because I assume
that the kiosk has a button to change
the language number one so if there's a
language barrier then you can instantly
change the language of the kiosk and
when you tell your order to a person
it's possible that they might hear you
incorrectly it's also possible that they
might hear you correctly but enter the
order incorrectly into the Machine so if
you're actually setting up the order you
put no pickles or extra hot sauce or
whatever uh and you put it in there
yourself you're at least eliminating one
place where mistakes could be made now
totally but I'm thinking more maybe of
elderly people who have a tough time
using these sorts of technology okay
because oftentimes I'll go to the
self-service checkout at the grocery
store and it's full of just people
complaining cuz they don't know how to
use it yelling over representatives
those often do break though in my
experience and they they don't work
right I've experienced that as well the
big picture here is that this is not
about a 12 or $15 minimum wage right the
big picture is we are going to
experience a total paradigm shift in
terms of the human relationship to labor
hours period almost everyone is missing
the boat on this it was not discussed
during the presidential campaign and if
you want to approach this by saying well
a $15 minimum wage is bad because those
places are the first to institute the
the automated ordering machines well it
also could be that they're putting these
machines in higher traffic areas which
are likely in urban areas like some of
the cities that are more likely to have
higher minimum wages so I don't think
that that's where the focus should be I
think if that's where you're focusing
you're sort of missing the boat do you
anticipate Pat ever trying one of these
machines at a McDonald's I don't I
honestly don't think there's anything I
can get at a McDonald's with my diet uh
viva pata fries are not vegan so is that
true I can't be on there yeah what are
the fries have that usually you would
expect fries to just be potato salt and
oil but they put this sort of beef sauce
over it is that true thoroughly they're
not even vegetarian yeah Wow I mean I
know most of the vegetarians I know
don't go to McDonald's but some of the
vegetation
and I know we'll go to McDonald and get
fries they probably have no idea that
they're not vegetarian today's program
is made possible in part by movement
watches @m VMT watches dot-com I've been
wearing my movement watch now for a few
weeks
everywhere I go it attracts attention
and people say hey what what watches
that that's really really cool
and the best thing about the watches is
that they're not expensive if you go to
those department stores and you want a
watch that looks this nice you're
probably looking at four to five hundred
dollars which is certainly more than I'm
willing to spend on a watch at least at
this point in my life
MVM t-- watches start at just 95 bucks
and you can get an extra 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns if
you go to NV empty watches dot-com slash
Pakman that is PA que MA and check out
all the watches 15% off free returns
free shipping @m VMT watches dot-com /
Pakman